Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Disney posted the second episode of Rebels
early again on iTunes and the Disney XD website
and it brought back a couple of old friends.
Also big heads up too, today at New York Comic
Con, they announced that they’d also be
airing a Guardians of The Galaxy animated
series on Disney XD next year.
This will just be a video for rebels, but
I wanted to let you know about Guardians just
in case you didn’t see the news.
Careful for Rebels Spoilers if you haven’t
seen the episode.
It’s free right now on itunes.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go
Top 5 moments
Number 5 - The Star Tours Robot RX-24
Star Tours was a disneyland ride from 1987
to 2010.
I hope you got a chance to ride it, but it
was like a virtual Star Wars adventure ride
that had a narrative and voice over work.
The droid that ushered you through everything
was RX-24, this guy right here.
So his cameo is very similar to what he did
and said on the disneyland ride.
The ship looks like the star tours ship too.
But you may recognize the voice being done
by paul reubens, he’s the same guy that
did the voice for the original ride.
Here’s a little bit of the original audio
from the ride.
It’s just awesome that they did this, it’s
a huge easter egg for anyone that got to go
on the ride.
Just for reference, disneyland replaced Star
Tours with an updated version of the ride
in 2011.
They brought a bunch of original cast members
like Carrie Fisher to do voices for the new
ride and Paul Reubens to do this RX-24 guy
again.
If any of you are Avatar Last Airbender or
Legend Of Korra fans, Dee Bradley Baker does
the voice for Boba Fett.
Number 4 - Zeb Backstory
We learn a ton about Zeb’s history before
the events on the show.
It’s a very similar story to what happened
to the Wookies on Kashyyyk.
It turns out Agent Kallus ordered the use
of these special disruptor guns on the Lasat
people during a big final assault on his home
planet.
It sounds like most of his people were killed.
We also learn he was a member of the honor
guard because of his special bow rifle.
Even though it looks like the staff weapons
used by general grievous’ droids in revenge
of the sith, the name bow rifle reminds me
of Chewbacca’s weapon, the bowcaster.
In case you didn’t see any of my other rebels
videos.
Zeb’s race, the lasat is based on the original
ralph mcquarrie concept drawings for Wookies.
So if you get chewbacca vibes from him.
It’s intentional.
Number 3 - C3PO & R2
It wouldn’t be Star Wars without a cameo
from these guys.
Turns out they were secretly on a mission
for bail organa, so they haven’t passed
into the service of Princess Leia yet.
In george lucas’ original story materials
for episode 4, he describes her as being between
13 and 15, so I’d say right now where we
are on the show, she’s only about 11.
In the expanded universe she became a senator
at 16, so the timeline is a little fuzzy.
I’m not sure how long she had been a senator
when episode 4 picks up.
This isn’t their show though, so I understand
that they didn’t start the story with the
droids.
In the original trilogy, George Lucas used
this old Akira Kurosawa technique to open
the movie with them.
Kurosawa would just open samurai films from
the perspective of lesser characters and as
you started to learn about the story from
them, they’d run into the main characters
and the perspective would shift.
It would have been cool if they did that in
this episode.
But I get why they chose not to.
They did kind of end the episode on a moment
like this when Bail Organa referred to them
as a couple of rebels.
Just making it seem like the crew of the ghost
were a small blip on the galaxy’s radar.
Number 2 - Zeb vs kallus
This really did turn into a Zeb Episode, which
is great.
It just means more Steven Blum.
We also found out that he and Kallus have
unkown history.
Zeb was learning Kallus was behind the massacre
on his home planet.
So what you’re seeing is the potential beginning
of a blood feud that will run across the rest
of the season.
Kallus was almost able to Kill Zeb this time,
so don’t be surprised if at some point Zeb
almost kills Kallus and it becomes an anakin
skywalker type situation where he has to decide
whether to kill him and go super dark or take
the high road and let him live, at the expense
of any future evil shennanigans Kallus might
commit.
There’s always that moral throughline in
star wars tv episodes, so if they chose the
right path in turning the guns over to Bail
Organa, then of course they won’t chose
to kill anyone if given the chance.
and my Number 1 moment - Bail Organa’s Ship
You may have recognized him, but Phil Lamaar
came back to do the voice for Bail.
He did the voice during Clone Wars.
In fact, so far, Rebels has used all the original
Clone Wars voice actors to do characters in
the new series when they get cameos.
Like Obi-Wan.
It’s cute that Kanan leaves without knowing
who Bail Organa is, but the really interesting
part was the last bit.
Him referring to the Ghost as a band of Rebels.
Disney was pretty clear that this tv series
would be kind of an origin story for the rebellion.
It’s not really about the rebellion though.
It’s just about this small group of people.
But the whole Spark of Rebellion first episode
implies that what they’ll be doing during
the tv series will inspire the people who
do form the rebellion.
Just as a brush up on your expanded universe
history.
The official leaders of the Rebellion were
Bail Organa, Mon Mothma and Garm Bel Iblis.
The listed date of formation, when the rebellion
officially became the rebel alliance was 2
years before episode 4.
So it might go down in a future season of
rebels unless they mess with the timeline.
If we saw Bail Organa, there’s a good chance
we’ll see the other leaders.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and did you ever go on the old star tours
ride or the new one?
Overall I gave the episode a solid B plus
for amazing use of nostalgia.
It’s very hard to create dramatic tension
when we already know what the endgame is,
so the work is really unfolding these stories
in new an interesting ways.
If you ever feel like the camera is lingering
on things for a long time, it’s probably
because they laid in some easter eggs, which
is really what I spend a lot of my time during
episodes doing.
Playing the game where you see how many special
things you can spot.
Like the landspeeder here.
This is the same model that was inside Owen
and Beru Lars farm.
You see it in episode 4 when luke starts cleaning
off 3PO and R2.
It’s a different color, but you get the
idea.
Then there’s the Bow rifle and the bowcaster,
there’s probably a ton of stuff I missed.
So if you spotted any objects or references
just write them in the comments.
The series is offically going to premiere
on Disney XD this monday, they’ll be airing
this episode.
It will be a monday night show from now on
out, so my videos will always post by tuesday
morning.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And yes, when the Guardians of The Galaxy
Cartoon announces the cast and releases more
footage I’ll start doing videos for it too.
Right now click here for my Rebels Episode
1 video and click here to catch up on Legend
of Korra.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and meet back up tomorrow, see ya guys!